when you're brainstorming
um we have this principle called like
one-third one-third one-third the first
third of the idea is let's say I gotta
go for about 30 ideas first third of the
ideas generally tend to be the usual
ideas eight to ten ideas they've thought
of them before we've experienced that
then if you go beyond that the next 10
10 or so tend to get a little goofier
they get a little funnier a little then
the third third is where the
breakthroughs begin to happen right
that's where the new ideas yeah and so
we call it the extended effort principle
now we're not talking a lot of time here
we're talking maybe 10 minutes all right
so yeah just by taking 10 minutes and so
what tends to happen is when you have a
well-defined problem once you go into
that process with the better ideas occur
earlier in the process because you've
already figured out what the problem is
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
20 minute leaders is a proud supporter
of Make-a-Wish Israel and Tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret Court Ventures J Ventures
Riverside Femme Fusion VC Birthright
Excel J impact leap Google for startups
and hippo and in media partnership with
ctek
hello welcome to 20 minute leaders let's
talk about how to be creative yes it's I
guess possible to learn to be more
creative and today I am with Roger
fierstein PhD who has trained more
people to lead the creative process than
anyone else in the world he is senior
faculty and associate professor at the
Center for Applied imagination at SUNY
Buffalo State University as president of
innovation resources and can consult
creates training programs runs
breakthrough labs and has created a
series of courses for open sesame he is
the author of several popular books
including creating a flash a Leader's
recipe for breakthrough innovation
I think I saw code the other day that
said you know in the age of AI and
robots what the only thing we have left
for us as humans is creativity the
ability to be created and I work in
natural language processing and a lot of
the things that I've been dealing with
over the last few months is you know
this whole notion of creativity and
originality I think we had a we had a
Google engineer the other day a clean
sentience for a machine so I think we
would the question of creativity is
coming up a lot these days and and here
you know Roger you're a creativity
expert I think we can we can call you
that and so first I want to understand
what does that even mean what does that
mean to be good at that creativity it's
really a great question
um and kind of to give you some history
on this
um and this might lead into that I uh I
am I'm originally from Colorado and and
and uh why don't we do the history could
that help because that'll lead into this
there's 100 and and so the the way I
kind of got to this is that I grew up on
a farm in Colorado and
um and my mother made me take piano
lessons right didn't like my piano
lessons right and when I was about 14 a
minister in our church gave me a little
four-string guitar
and I fell in love with this guitar and
practicing and playing music and that
eventually led me to teaching music in a
music studio doing private guitar
lessons and so I went off to college at
the University of Northern Colorado
expected to become a music Major I was
going to be like a band teacher or
something like that
and uh to make my way through college I
taught guitar lessons and I was finding
that my students were getting bored with
their initial lessons and so I had the
idea that if I could get them to get a
little bit more creative they'd enjoy
their music more interesting so this is
the summer of 1975
1976 and I started reading about
creativity
and there's this one place and two names
that kept coming up consistently in the
literature and this place was called the
interdisciplinaries for the center for
creativity studies at a place called
Buffalo State College in Buffalo New
York and then these two names Sid Parnes
and Ruth noler and these were like the
the founders of the field well
um in the summer of in early 1977 I
called out here and I discovered that I
actually got to talk to Sid par and so
that was crazy it was 21 years old I
never talked to an author in my life
um I got goosebumps so um I found out
that they had this graduate program in
creativity studies which is the science
and the study of creativity how we
create how we come up with ideas that's
based on a process and we can talk more
about that a little bit and they had
this annual conference and so in uh June
of 1977 I flew out here from Colorado
came to Buffalo New York studied went to
this creative problem solving Institute
which was a gathering of people from all
over the world studying various aspects
of creativity and then there's a
graduate program that they had just
started and so I took a course in that
and uh when I went back to Colorado my
mom and my dad said all you could talk
about was creativity and the work that
you did out there and you were just so
on fire with that so I finished up my
degree and then I moved out here in 1978
and I got my master's degree in
creativity studies in 1979. and and I
think I was like the fifth or the ninth
person fifth or the seventh person to
get the degree and now we graduated over
like four I'm sorry 800 graduate
students wow yeah in with with degrees
Yeah and now it's called creativity and
change leadership so what's the science
of creativity well our approach is
really based on a process
and it's based on the work done by a
gentleman named Alex Osborne now Alex
Osborne invented brainstorming he was an
advertising executive and he's the own
the advertising agency bbdo yeah and his
concern was is that he had these young
advertising Executives and they were
very very talented but they weren't
creative and then he goes well you guys
gotta get creative well the problem was
is they weren't trained to be creative
and so Osborne read all of the earlier
books on creativity you know sort of the
the process the natural process of
creativity of you know you prepare for a
long time and you kind of let the idea
incubate then you get this idea the aha
moment and then and then you uh you
verify it well that's great if you get a
lot of time but what Osborne was after
was the whole concept of deliberate
creativity how do you turn you on your
creativity at will and it's just
something to happen yeah yeah and then
he invented brainstorming which is a
technique for coming up with lots of
ideas but that wasn't enough and so it's
not just an have to come up with ideas
you need to make sure that you're
solving the right problem and so he
developed this whole process of first
decide what you want to work on get some
data around it Define the problem and
and we can talk more about problem
definition because that's some of the
work that I'm working on right now
generate ideas for solving it select the
best of those ideas refine them and then
build an action plan and so that's where
my work has really been been over the
last 45 plus years is around the whole
creative process how do we deliberately
make creativity happen in individuals
and in organizations and I've been
teaching that for years and writing
about it and stuff and and and so that's
kind of been the work and and the
passion around that so that's really
where when you talk about what
creativity is my whole focus is on
deliberate creativity it's a little bit
more about how you can turn your
creativity on it will how you can solve
the right problem we can talk some more
about that as we get we get further in
but but that's um that's kind of the
journey so far yeah I mean I think it
sounds to me like there's sort of you
know a few different camps one of people
when it comes to creativity there are
some people that they say you know it's
a sort of this kind of spark that you
have you know in the shower or you know
when you're doing something random and
and that is sort of the this initial
idea and then there's I guess other
Notions of okay how do we how can we
develop techniques to actually come up
with these same innovative ideas but but
in in the more deliberate places and I
think that that's what you mentioned
that's where your art is right you are
in the deliberate phase yeah and it's
the yes and and one of the things that
we found is that after you do a session
where you're deliberately generating
lots of ideas and Michael I'm talking
about in a period of five minutes a
trained group can come up with that's
150 you know 200 ideas for solving the
problem it's very time efficient the
challenge that comes is sorting it
through that's what takes the time not
right sure yeah but what we've done is
we've done studies where and this is my
some of my early studies that I did is
that I found that after I was in a
session like this you kind of get the
wheels rolling okay and then that's when
the idea comes up in the shower again
boom so when I work with groups and I
say say now we've done some work on
generating some ideas for this problem
I recommend that you keep a paper or you
keep your smartphone ready by you
because you're going to have this has
stirred some things up you're going to
have some ideas that are just going to
come to you just almost naturally
capture them because you got stuff shook
loose up here and you're going to make
some more connections and we've got some
research around that actually validates
that so so it is a yes and yeah
and so is this how much of this is you
know more science-based you know
Neuroscience trying to figure out what
what's happening in the brain what's
happening and physiologically rather
than you know a little bit more
um
I I don't even know what I don't know I
guess uh random spiritual I think you
can help me classify this better yeah
let's go to that because what I'd got a
degree in is I got a master of science
okay not a master of arts and to be able
to prove that this stuff works is this
creativity training works we had to
validate that so in the late 1960s early
1970s the largest study on the on the on
the deliberate uh General the largest
study of the deliberate fostering of
creativity was conducted at SUNY Buffalo
State and what they did was they took
freshmen they divide them into two
groups um they gave them four semesters
of training and creative problem solving
back as it was back then they evaluated
the results they threw all sorts of
psychological instruments at him and
what they found was that the folks that
were training this stuff
um did better in math uh they came up
they came up with English topics better
but the big thing was is they were able
to solve personal problems like getting
along with their roommates getting along
with parents much much better because
they learned this process yeah so so
that's kind of the science side of it
now the other side of it is is like it's
such an extraordinary phenomenon and you
know we look at creativity because it's
all inclusive and researchers have
studied creativity in like four areas
the creative person the creative process
the creative product or the creative
environment we call that press kind of
the interaction of the person of the
environment sure now the creative person
that's sort of the psychological
approach and you know that's the people
that are studying these folks that you
know you see that seem to be naturally
creative coming up with ideas okay
that's a personality approach the other
one is the process approach which is why
I'm involved in product approach that's
Aesthetics you know that's art that's
product development and then the
environment for creativity a lot of
other folks in the organizational Arena
have studied that what's the environment
that we can create in organizations to
help our people to become more creative
we can certainly talk about as well
because I've spent some time there as
well so so that's kind of the way we
study it so it's a yes and you know it
is both deliberate it is both
unconscious it is both spiritual and now
we have
um CT scans and we have um Neuroscience
that's actually showing us
um how folks are actually
um how their brains are lighting up when
they're making ideas and and it is not
just your right brain it's not not just
your left brain but creativity is a
whole brain phenomenon so when you're
coming up with ideas when you're solving
to create a problem what they find is
the whole brain lights up because it's
all of this stuff is going on up there
you're making connections you're
redefining problems you're working in in
in in spaces that are that are
non-verbal you're working in verbal
spaces so yeah interesting so what are
some non-trivial things that myself and
perhaps some of my young entrepreneurial
friends should keep in mind as we're
thinking through creativity or being
creative As Leaders or creating a
creative culture within our companies
yeah let's let's talk about let me make
sure I get to the creative culture okay
because we're doing some writing about
that so there's a couple things that you
can do first off
and work on a book right now called
solve the real problem because as I've
worked through this business in the last
40 plus years there's about a 99 chance
of what you think is the problem really
isn't the problem at all it's a symptom
it's what the boss tells you it's the
problem it's the first impression of
what you think is a problem yeah so
first thing to do is that when you
encounter a problem is pause okay and
I'm not saying you know pause for a long
time take about five to six minutes to
figure out what you really believe the
problem is and the way we do that is we
generate what we call Creative questions
now people are real familiar with
generating creative ideas all right you
know that's kind of the way people think
about creativity brainstorming would
come up with lots of ideas but I but
we're working now let's back up and
let's generate a lot just like we
generate lots of ideas when we're
solving a problem let's generate lots of
creative questions and we start them
with words like how to or how might me
or what might be all the ways to so come
up with 10 or 15 creative questions how
to how might how to then when you've
done that you've had a pretty good look
at the problem space then pick the
creative question that looks the best
for you generate some ideas for solving
that now we've got some research studies
on that and a number of years ago a
colleague of mine did a study
any divided groups these were students
eat a vitamin that's because you did a
lot of research on students so I need to
buy these groups into two groups and one
group was given a problem to solve and
another group was given the same problem
to solve the first group they said now
just go to work on the problem and
solvent okay then they evaluate the
ideas for originality and Effectiveness
the second group they said now figure
out what the real problem is first and
then generate ideas for solving it and
what they found was that the group that
spent the time figuring out what the
real problem was had better ideas more
original ideas ideas that really did
this solve the problem now in the
research study I I discovered that they
didn't tell me how much time it took for
these folks to redefine the problem so I
called the researcher actually emailed
them and and I said this was work done
by a gentleman named Mark runco I said
Mark in your study you didn't say how
much time you gave these people to
redefine the problem they said well
actually he said we gave him no time
limit he said we said take as much time
as you want to do to find the problem
but in actuality they took between five
to six minutes to redefine what the
problem was and they came up with
significantly better ideas interest so
just by stepping back you know taking
five five minutes you know figure out
what the real problem is first then
generate ideas for solving that but most
people or many people they think problem
answer problem answer problem answered
so just by pausing generating a few
creative questions and then
um them so then during ideas for solving
it the effectiveness is extraordinary
and the few times where we found that
the best and so oftentimes what then it
happens is that you'll get your better
ideas early on in the process oftentimes
when you're generating ideas and you
probably experience this when you're
brainstorming
um we have this principle called like
one-third one-third one-third the first
third of the idea is let's say you're
gonna go for about 30 ideas first third
of the ideas generally tend to be the
usual ideas eight to ten ideas if you've
thought of them before we've experienced
that then if you go beyond that the next
10 to 10 or so tend to get a little
goofier they get a little funnier then
the third third is where the
breakthroughs begin to happen that's
where the new ideas yeah and so we call
it the extended effort principle now
we're not talking a lot of time here
we're talking maybe 10 minutes all right
so yeah just by taking 10 minutes and so
what tends to happen is when you have a
well-defined problem once you go into
that process with the better ideas occur
earlier in the process because you've
already figured out what the problem is
so
um that's just some one is figure out
what the real problem is first before
you go off this of it and I can say that
that's probably and then when you're
coming up with ideas don't judge them
just let them come out and then another
thing that we like to use is creativity
is connection making and so we have a
technique called forced connections
where we ask you to just look around the
room and say you know what ideas to get
my from my smartphone for solving this
or from that clock over there from the
books Making Connections that way
because if you look at the history of
creativity it's the it's the connection
making process for example
um a number of years ago I interviewed
the the gentleman that invented the
pacemaker and his information his his
inspiration for the pacemaker was a
flashing traffic signal but interesting
boom yeah yeah and there's countless
example examples of that in some science
and art where you make a connection from
one area into another area and so when
we have people working on problems
together we ask people to come from
different disciplines to be working on
it because as you've experienced if you
have the same people from to have the
same knowledge so the the thing is I go
into an organization they say well we
need to have all the technical people on
this problem I'll say well if the
technical people haven't solved it why
do we have more technical people at it
all right and so when we work with
organizations
um and we bring in people that we call
Creative catalysts they're trained in
Creative problem solving they don't know
the problem and it's amazing the stuff
that happens so that's a product that
we're called the Breakthrough lab that
we're doing and it's working out great
it works virtually and in person so yeah
why why are you so invested in this why
do you care so much about creativity
about helping people become creative why
what is it about
your work that you that you're that ties
back to sort of who you are as a person
I am so glad you asked that question
because as I Was preparing for this I
thought more about that and and I I
think there's a couple of things one
when I'm teaching
um I love to watch the light bulbs come
on on people's in people's heads and and
I teach the introductory graduate class
level I don't teach the advanced level
because my philosophy is is that if you
get the basics down well you're going to
be fine and I've seen people coming to
classes because we work on real problems
it's like we apply this process to what
you want to work on so for example one
young lady came in this is probably
about 45 years four or five years ago
she said I want to lose weight okay well
we worked and we redefined the problem
and this class met on the weekends so a
few weeks later we met again and she
came back and she said I want to tell
you what I've done since we had our last
class she goes I I published a book I
started on when I was four
um I've started a non-profit
organization
um I'm um putting together a calendar
that works on that raises money for uh
domestic violence prevention
and then six months later down the road
she is at our state capitol proposing
legislation to deal with domestic
violence all right because and because
she redefined the problem from and then
and then so I saw her about a year or so
later for she was taking an advanced
class and
I said hey how are you she goes you know
what I lost the weight I'm paying back
the student loans and the legislation is
going through it's stuff like that I
mean people start businesses they start
relationships
um and you know I was thinking about
this today
um just about all of the faculty now at
the center for creativity and change
leadership they've been my students and
um and now I get to they get to teach me
so that's one thing and and then you
know as as I was coming up on this it
was the interaction it was working with
the groups it was it was working with
students and I still love the teaching
but I'm really finding a lot of fun now
you know working on the on the new books
like uh creating a flash uh why didn't I
think of that which is a release and now
the new book called solve the real
problem because these books are
different
um they're pictures we we have an art
director and you know there's there's a
whole variety you open up the book and
it's it's kind of my my view as a book
should be a work of art and when you
open this book up it's like boy that's
really cool that's really cool and so so
there's that and and then and then as I
was thinking about this
um I I also kind of went back to kind of
my personal vision and
um I think I came up with this like
sometime in like the early 80s and I
have it here and and it's um my vision
has been to make creativity simple make
creativity practical and help people of
Pride creativity in their world make
creativity simple make it practical and
help people apply creativity in their
world yeah and so if it's not simple
people aren't going to use it and so
there's a lot of yeah there's a lot of
Science and stuff that goes around this
and you know people will oftentimes you
know conflict conflate things because
you know that's kind of the nature of
not but no no we just cut through all
that make it simple so yeah incredible
yeah Roger yeah I want to thank you so
much for for this time 20 minutes ago
fly by so fast but I I absolutely loved
it and I thank you and I I definitely
supports my curiosity for figuring out
what is creativity and how to Foster
creativity and so I I look forward to
checking more of your work and uh and
then learning more from your journey so
thank you very very much thank you
Michael it was my pleasure thank you
thank you
foreign